Descartes se serait moqué de cette scène
en disant qu’il s’agit simplement
d’un robot sur un robot.
Bah oui, pour lui,
Haristote est une machine !
Ne t’inquiète pas,
c’est des bêtises.
Enfin bon,
on peut quand même se demander :
est-ce qu’un chihuahua est vraiment
comparable à une machine ?
Je suis Romain,
je suis avec Haristote,
le cobaye de cette vidéo,
et vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Une des théories les plus connues de Descartes
est celle de l’animal-machine,
qu’il expose notamment
dans sa Lettre au Marquis de Newcastle.
Pas besoin d’un dessin,
l’idée c’est que Haristote ne serait
en réalité
rien d’autre qu'une machine élaborée.
C’est la physique mécaniste du début du
XVIIe siècle
qui a inspiré cette théorie au philosophe.
En gros,
le monde est rempli de substances,
de corps,
qui ont des caractéristiques géométriques
et qui peuvent s'entrechoquer
et ainsi se transmettre le mouvement de proche
en proche.
C’est donc ça,
la vision du monde qui réduit Haristote à
un robot.
Allez, on va un peu plus dans le détail.
Alors, je précise que, pour faire cette vidéo,
j’ai sollicité l’avis du vétérinaire
d'Haristote
le docteur Feraoun, qui éxerce à Paris,
un vétérinaire exceptionnel
dans la mesure où il est aussi un érudit,
qui aime la philosophie.
Je me souviens d’ailleurs que la première
fois que je suis venu,
on a parlé des théories d’Aristote
- le philosophie, pas le chien.
Regardez donc la vidéo jusqu’à la conclusion,
parce que je vous y dirai ce que pense le
docteur Feraoun
de la théorie de l’animal-machine
- et vous verrez que son avis est très intéressant,
parce que c’est l’avis de quelqu’un
qui est à la fois
un expert scientifique des animaux,
un praticien qui les connaît de très près,
qui a beaucoup d’expérience,
mais c’est aussi l’avis
de quelqu’un qui interroge sa pratique avec
du recul,
qui réfléchit beaucoup
au rapport de l’homme à l’animal,
et qui est très au fait des débats
passés et contemporains.
Bref, j’ai trouvé les explications du docteur
Feraoun passionnantes
- c’est probablement, je pense,
l’avis le plus éclairé possible sur la
question
à l’heure actuelle.
Vous allez voir que la théorie de l’animal-machine
est importante
parce qu’elle a des implications pour l’homme.
Eh oui,
est-ce que je suis fondamentalement
si différent de Haristote ?
J’espère que la réponse est oui.
La théorie de l’animal-machine réduit
un chihuahua
à sa dimension mécanique.
En effet,
Descartes explique le comportement animal
entièrement par l’instinct.
Or, l’instinct,
c'est un ensemble de mécanismes
qui s’activent automatiquement
en réaction aux signaux produits par les
circonstances.
Chaque stimulus extérieur entraîne
une réponse comportementale
que l’homme peut prévoir.
Par exemple,
si je présente un bel os à Haristote,
il va systématiquement devenir fou,
parce que son instinct lui fait voir l’os
comme une ressource cruciale pour sa survie.
Comme Descartes écrit à l’époque des
premières poupées articulées,
dont le fonctionnement émerveille le public,
il ne voit aucune différence
entre ces petites machines produites par l’homme
et les animaux.
C’est juste que les animaux
sont mécaniquement beaucoup plus élaborés.
Mais ils ne sont, en définitive,
que des combinaisons de pièces formant des
rouages,
sans conscience
ni pensée.
Au XVIIIe siècle, par exemple,
l’inventeur Jacques Vaucanson aurait créé
un canard artificiel,
le « Canard digérateur »,
capable de nager et de digérer
comme un véritable canard.
Son but, c’était de montrer
que les mouvements vitaux
dépendent entièrement des lois de la mécanique.
Alors, Descartes entrevoit tout de même une
objection :
les animaux font beaucoup de choses mieux
que les hommes.
Par exemple,
Haristote entend beaucoup mieux que moi.
Certes,
mais est-ce que le comportement animal
en est moins mécanique ?
Est-ce qu’une machine fait forcément moins
bien que l’homme ?
Au contraire.
Une montre, par exemple,
indique bien mieux l’heure que moi.
Bon, on l’a compris,
pour Descartes,
Haristote est juste une machine élaborée.
Désolé.
Mais moi,
qu’est-ce que je suis alors ?
La mécanique du corps humain
À bien considérer mon corps,
eh bien il ne serait pas si différent que
ça
de celui d'Haristote.
Bien sûr,
je suis plus grand, plus lourd, etc.
Mais moi aussi j’ai un instinct
- certes probablement beaucoup plus atténué
-
un instinct qui me fait réagir de manière
mécanique
aux stimuli de mon environnement.
Par exemple,
vous avez peut-être déjà eu droit,
chez le médecin,
à un petit coup de marteau sur le genou.
En fait,
c’est un examen clinique pour tester les
réflexes des tendons
- c’est pour ça que le marteau s’appelle
un « marteau à réflexes ».
Si tout va bien,
le corps doit normalement faire un mouvement
immédiat,
totalement involontaire et stéréotypé…
comme s'il était une machine programmée
!
Pour Descartes,
le corps humain est donc aussi comparable
à une machine.
Vu que la matière est entièrement régie
par des causes mécaniques,
qu’elle ne peut être expliquée
que par la physique et les mathématiques,
et que mon corps est fait de matière,
eh bien il obéit entièrement à des lois
mécaniques,
qui sont pour Descartes
les lois universelles de la nature.
Ce faisant,
Descartes écarte
- difficile la prononciation là -
notamment le vitalisme,
la doctrine selon laquelle
il existerait une force vitale
qui serait à l’origine du mouvement de
la matière vivante,
et dont les lois mécaniques ne pourraient
pas rendre compte.
Non,
comme tout objet,
le corps humain est caractérisé,
sur le plan physique,
par des propriétés matérielles.
Nous on se focalise surtout sur la taille
et le poids,
mais il y a bien sûr plein d’autres mensurations
possibles.
Et toutes ces mensurations sont la preuve,
pour Descartes,
que le corps est simplement une portion d’étendue
découpée dans la réalité matérielle.
Oui mais alors,
ça veut dire que je ne suis pas
fondamentalement différent d’un chihuahua
?
Est-ce que l’homme serait une machine
au même titre qu’un chihuahua ?
NON.
Ouf !
Descartes sauve l’honneur en précisant
que j’ai une âme,
tandis que Haristote n’aurait pas d’âme.
Pourtant…
quand je le regarde dans les yeux,
j’ai parfois l’impression qu’il y a
quelque chose…
Pour Descartes,
je suis plus qu’une machine
grâce à l’union
entre mon corps
(qui est une substance étendue)
et mon âme
(qui est une substance pensante).
La théorie de l’animal-machine est donc
dualiste,
c’est-à-dire qu’elle distingue d’un
côté un monde matériel,
dont tous les éléments sont caractérisés
par des propriétés physiques,
et de l’autre côté un monde spirituel,
ou immatériel,
dont les éléments, comme la pensée,
échappent au champ de la physique.
À ce propos,
je vous invite à aller voir ma vidéo
sur la conception de l’âme et du corps
de Platon
- qui est également dualiste -
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui s’affiche
en haut à droite,
soit sur celui qui est dans la description.
Je reviens à mes moutons :
comme j’ai une âme,
je suis capable de raisonner dans un contexte
particulier,
et ça,
ça ne s’explique pas par les lois mécaniques.
La meilleure preuve de cette dimension spirituelle
de l’être humain,
c’est d’après Descartes
l’aptitude au langage,
qui témoigne de l’activité de la pensée.
Il y aurait donc
une frontière nette
entre l’animalité et l’humanité,
en vertu de laquelle l’homme serait supérieur
à l’animal.
Après,
tout le monde n’est pas d’accord avec
Descartes,
loin de là.
Pythagore,
qui était végétarien,
pensait lui que l’homme et l’animal
sont tous deux l’expression du même esprit
vital.
C’est mieux ça, non ?
On peut aussi penser à Montaigne,
qui a affirmé que la distance séparant certains
hommes
peut être supérieure à celle séparant
l’homme de l’animal.
Il y a eu aussi une extension,
par La Mettrie,
de la théorie de l’animal-machine,
qui est devenue l’homme-machine.
Ce philosophe et médecin libertin affirme
même
que Descartes pensait déjà comme lui,
en fait,
mais qu’il a conservé l’hypothèse de
l’âme
(la « substance pensante »)
comme un gage donné aux théologiens.
Et enfin,
plus récemment,
le philosophe australien Peter Singer,
qui a écrit la Bible des mouvements de protection
des animaux,
le livre qui s’intitule La libération animale,
- ce philosophe a critiqué la théorie de
Descartes
en rétorquant que la souffrance animale est
un enjeu moral
en vertu duquel
eh bien un animal ne peut pas être comparé
à une machine.
Je vous invite à aller voir la vidéo
que j’ai réalisée à propos de ce livre,
La libération animale,
encore une fois soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit sur celui qui est dans la description.
Bref,
Descartes n’a pas eu le dernier mot.
Ça n’est donc pas certain qu'Haristote
soit un robot,
ou alors j’en suis peut-être un moi aussi
- mais plus élaboré quand même.
En synthèse,
Descartes considère que l’animal est une
machine
parce que son comportement serait déterminé
par les lois mécaniques,
tandis que l’homme, lui,
a une âme,
une substance pensante
dont la vie
n’est pas réductible aux lois mécaniques.
Mais la dignité d'Haristote est défendue
par son vétérinaire.
Pour le docteur Feraoun,
Haristote invalide, au contraire,
la théorie de Descartes,
parce qu’il a une grande capacité d’adaptation.
Si vous prenez des fourmis,
c’est vrai qu’elles sont très dépendantes
de leur atavisme,
de leur état génétique
- elles reproduisent un programme
sans le modifier.
Mais un chien est un animal social,
qui s’adapte à son maître,
et plus globalement à son environnement.
Il peut être un compagnon,
ou un chasseur ;
il est plus ou moins agressif,
en fonction de son environnement.
Bref,
Haristote n’est pas du tout un automate,
parce qu’il s’adapte de manière permanente
- ce qui est la définition de la vie.
Si je reviens à l’exemple du bel os que
je lui présente,
c’est vrai que Haristote réagit de manière
mécanique,
quand il devient fou,
mais le docteur Feraoun m’a expliqué
que ce qui se passe dans le cerveau d'Haristote
n’est pas si différent de ce qui se passe
dans MON cerveau,
par exemple quand je vois un pot de nutella.
La neurochimie est similaire :
le désir et le plaisir
se manifestent par des neurotransmetteurs,
comme la dopamine,
qui existe aussi chez le chien.
D’ailleurs,
les psychotropes utilisés pour les chiens
sont fondamentalement les mêmes
que ceux utilisés pour les hommes.
Le deuxième point des explications du docteur
Feraoun,
c’est que la comparaison de l’animal à
une machine
est en fait une question franco-française.
La théorie de Descartes a eu une influence
très longue et très profonde,
et c’est ce qui explique le retard de la
France
dans la prise en compte de la souffrance animale.
Le philosophe La Mettrie dont je vous ai parlé,
l’auteur de la théorie de l’homme-machine,
choquait ses visiteurs
en donnant de violents coups de pied
à sa chienne enceinte qui hurlait de douleur,
mais on tuait encore les chatons
en les jetant dans un sac contre un mur
jusqu'aux années 1980 1990.
Le docteur Feraoun m’a raconté que des
opérations
qu’il avait apprises à l’école vétérinaire,
- comme couper les oreilles ou la queue -
ont été progressivement supprimées,
car jugées trop barbares ;
et qu’inversement,
les pratiques sont de plus en plus adaptées
pour minimiser la douleur animale
grosso modo depuis une quinzaine d’années
- c’est donc effectivement très récent
en France.
Troisième et dernier point des explications
du docteur Feraoun :
la théorie de l’animal-machine s’éclaire
aujourd’hui
à la lumière des progrès de l’intelligence
artificielle.
En effet,
si une véritable intelligence artificielle
est possible,
alors l’animal ET l’homme seraient des
machines,
mais pas de simples automates,
des machines très élaborées !
Mais si,
en revanche,
il est impossible de créer une authentique
intelligence artificielle,
équivalente à l’intelligence humaine,
alors ni l’homme NI l’animal
ne seraient véritablement comparables
à des machines.
En conclusion,
la distinction radicale de l’homme et de
l’animal
que fait Descartes
ne semble plus pertinente aujourd’hui,
car derrière la théorie de l’animal-machine
se profile toujours celle de l’homme-machine.
Et ce qui se profile encore derrière,
c’est la question
de la définition de la vie même.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo,
mettez un pouce bleu
et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire ma synthèse de la théorie de l’animal-machine
de Descartes
sur le site 1000 idées de culture générale,
le lien est dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale
synthétisées dans le format le plus clair
possible,
vous pouvez vous inscrire à la newsletter
en laissant votre adresse e-mail sur le site.
Enfin,
je remercie le docteur Feraoun pour ses explications
passionnantes,
qui m’ont permis de voir tous les enjeux
de la question.
Je suis Romain
et sous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous vous n’avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête
pour vous intéresser au meilleur de la pensée.